and this is why all these four stupid
Greeks that have a hundred percent of
their assets and in Greece they're in
big trouble now
Greece China Puerto Rico
Isis Donald Trump the world is going to
hell in a handbasket
which means the Doug Casey is rubbing
his hands with glee Doug Casey is a
crisis investor of long repute he's been
in the financial newsletter world he's
made more money than you can think of he
joins us here for the recent TV Doug
thank you for joining us well my
pleasure Matt I'll of being on reason TV
so how do we make money in the current
global crisis such as it exists this is
metaphysically impossible actually how
can everything be overpriced because
it's a relative thing overpriced
relative to what the stock markets all
around the world are in near bubble
territory the bond markets are in super
bubble territory of historic measure
real estate is overpriced everywhere so
what can you buy there's very little
what's happening with these stupid
government's printing up trillions and
trillions of new currency units not just
the Americans the Chinese the Japanese
the Europeans and all kinds of little
countries are doing the same thing it's
spilling up to a catastrophe of historic
proportions
isn't there some argument that if
everybody's doing it it'll somehow be
okay because that's the kind of
equilibrium that we now have going
forward
no contraire I live in Argentina and
they're quite used to these things and
when the Argentine cyclically
destroy their currency the Brazilians do
the same thing it's not like it's a big
problem in the country but it's soluble
because the people outside the country
the overseas Argentines and Brazilians
that keep their money outside of the
country can bring it back in and rebuild
as conformers but when this happens on a
worldwide basis which it's gonna happen
this time there's nobody to bail you out
I think this is gonna be much worse and
much different than what happened in the
1930s and right now as we speak in the
middle of 2015 the economic clock on the
wall to me seems like it's about the
same time as it was in 2007 followed by
2008 or more appropriate
they actually were at about the same
time we would have been in 1929 is there
any validity to a critique that hey look
you know these are all these guys are
always bearish they're always claiming
catastrophe they're always saying buy
gold and etc so true if you're something
of a perma bear you have to feel like
that broken clock is Right twice a day
which is what you're saying but most of
the reading that I do is either ancient
history or science and technology and
the United States has been going
downhill since the McKinley regime now
technology has been getting better but
from a social point of view from a
philosophical point of view we've been
declining since then and in actual
economic terms in terms of what the
average guy is able to do
we've been going downhill since the mid
70s and as any institution gets larger
and older it neva tably becomes corrupt
and falls this is why nothing lasts
forever so I mean do we just bury gold
with our bags of rice in the field
somewhere I mean it's pretty dreary an
apocalyptic what you well how do we
respond as individuals to protect
ourselves from that order you make money
off it I always look at the bright side
of things as you can tell yeah and the
bright side of a crisis is that it
offers a lot of opportunity to profit
right now at 11:50 we're Golub is about
it's not as cheap as it was in 2001 but
the situation is so much more dangerous
now it's probably just as good a value
but then when you buy your goal where
are you gonna put it bury it in your
backyard I say put it in the safest
place you can think of and this is
problematical because what is the safest
place you can think of safe deposit box
probably not I wouldn't keep significant
capital in banks most of the banks in
the world are bankrupt just as the Greek
banks are look the average person is so
brain-dead these Greeks left their money
in Greek banks when it was possible even
a month ago to ship it out to a Swiss or
a German bank why did they do that I
don't know before we leave you have to
tell me one cheerful thing
well look there is cause for optimism in
the world there are two main Springs of
human progress one is science and
technology and there are more scientists
and engineers alive today than have
lived in all of previous history put
together the second thing is the average
person intuitively understands he's got
to produce more than he consumes and
save the difference the way a squirrel
puts away nuts in the fall against the
winter well I can't give you an alloy
good news let me throw a caution out
there it's that you know the government
might destroy all that capital like all
those Greeks that have squirrel their
nuts away for many years the nuts have
vanished it was in the form of euros in
the bank and the euros have disappeared
and gone to money heaven basically that
can happen here in the US and going back
well what about the scientists and
engineers they're gonna still improve
things yes they can but science in
today's world is capital intensive if
that capital that was in banks
disappears then the scientists and
engineers can't do what they're doing
either so maybe we'll have a new Dark
Age but on the other hand maybe we'll
have a cyclical recovery and we'll be
able to buy assets cheaply well guard
your nuts
thank you very much Casey for that
cheery outlook on the world for Reason
TV I am Matt well